already eyeball to eyeball with russia
america is about to face off tomorrow
with communist china president biden
said to speak on the phone with
president xi to discuss allegations that
russia asked china for financial and
military assistance to help russia in
its illegal war against ukraine
both beijing and moscow denying those
reports of real russian collusion but
biden is still warning of severe
consequences for china if it tries to
bail out putin these high-stakes talks
coming as worries grow that china might
be taking notes from russia when it
comes to expanding territory listen to
this
i think what is going on right now is
china is literally taking notes on
everything that's happening on russia
and ukraine right this is a parallel
situation to if they ever decided to go
to taiwan
so they are watching very closely how
the world reacts i'm clear that xi
jinping and the prc military leadership
is watching every single move i think
taiwan is certainly watching that i'm
confident that the xi jinping's not only
watching what's going on
in ukraine today but he's watching us
sit at a table in vienna while the
russians are killing innocent women and
children
i mean it really seems to me judge it
stinks it looks like china is playing
both sides they're playing russia
helping them russia the more desperate
they get the more china will give them a
helping hand on the other hand they want
the united states and the rest of the
world to say oh no china's pragmatic
china's practical china wants peace
they're good business people they're
playing us they're playing both sides
against the middle i think they're
playing us first of all they never
condemned the invasion by putin that's
number one number two they initially con
call the invasion some kind of military
um uh i'm not sure uh some special
operations special operations
yeah this week they called it a war
so now what you see is that china is
starting to recognize that the world is
starting to go against russia and i
think that china
has to realize that it's going to be
sanctioned as well economically and it
will suffer and it will suffer if the
united states acts quicker than it has
done as it relates to
ukraine because uh china is our number
one trading partner in terms of uh
export or import i have i have the
yeah uh got a lot of it so china is
walking a tightrope not just wondering
what the united states is going to do
they've already got the message united
states
china is a force for bad they want to
survive they want to invade taiwan they
want to be able to uh survive
economically they don't believe in
democracy they they parroted the talking
points of the russians that the reason
for the invasion in ukraine was because
of biolabs or because of later nato and
military buildup
judge mentioned taiwan
isn't taiwan the parallel russia
believes ukraine is part of russia china
believes taiwan is part of china
russia invaded ukraine now china can
invade taiwan you worry
no they're not that stupid that would be
suicide even worse than what russia is
committed
taiwan is like the world's greatest chip
manufacturer you think the economy the
world economy is bad now this is just
ukraine this is like some high-tech
stuff that everybody needs so if they go
in there you're going to have an
economic recession you haven't seen
anything like that the sanctions that we
would hit the chinese with would destroy
their economy their economy is already
starting to slow down and they're a
little bit worried about it so i don't
think they're going to make that move
but we should just arm them to the teeth
already don't wait until it's too late
yep don't wait till it's too late don't
give them any ideas you know
it was too late what we did with
everything in in ukraine i would load up
right now get the package out the door
do you think degen that china is a is a
honest broker do they want peace on
earth or do they want the communist
world to triumph
uh they want communism to triumph they
have a propaganda machine that rivals is
even better than brushes
and they've got million two million
uyghurs in concentration camps the west
won't turn against china uh the western
companies turned against russia because
it was expendable it's the 11th largest
economy in the world
you have seen companies and corporate
executives larry fink to name one the
nba fallen all over themselves to make
sure oh you can't insult china you
jeopardize our business there one thing
china has probably learned watching what
russia
is doing to ukraine is if they want to
take taiwan it's going to be done in the
dark no it'll be a black ops deal a
black ops operation they will make sure
that the rest of the world cannot see
what is going on in taiwan but i just
biden we call it a showdown it's a lay
down he hasn't even stood up and said to
uh she although he biden lied about it
stood up and said to she um you gotten
to the bottom of the origins of kovid
and what about the second plague the
fentanyl plague that you've unleashed on
the united states we've got almost a
million people dead here do you want to
do you want to talk about that
you have to talk about that i want him
to talk about all of it and and the war
it's a lot all of it it's a lot right
so greg what do you think
well i don't have let me ask you a quick
question i'm sorry let me interrupt you
uh do you think that china really asked
russia to not invade until the olympics
were over it's it's a very on-the-nose
kind of story so i'm a little skeptical
but i like the story
and i i i don't i'm not here's actually
here's a better answer to that now that
i think about it
they didn't think it was going to be a
big deal they thought this was going to
be a simple fling putin was just going
to do this little kind of thing like
crimea was going to be over no big deal
now china has buyer's remorse right they
didn't count on global revulsion walk of
shame they got a walk of shame after
this one night stand plus a foreign
policy std that's not going away
foreign policy std that's better than
the the mustache right you know what
remi you know what you know what the
best analogy for china in russia is
cnn and michael avenatti do you remember
how cnn embraced michael avenatti you
know you should run for president you
know michael avenatti is russia yeah
he'd be a great at eight o'clock i bet
he could probably replace that other guy
and then what happens is all of a sudden
avenatti turns out to be a real
sleazeball and cnn is running from it
like you know it's got like four
different who michael yeah
that's what's happened i think i think
china is at this place where like you
know what what used to be a our customer
is now a burden
and what do you do with burdens were
they going to back china is china going
to back russia or not it's up to biden's
fines i wish he was a forceful
persuasive communicator because it's
really up to him and i don't think he's
up to it there's no
they should be sending obama and trump
and get cheated wouldn't that be nice
wouldn't that be nice hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else